let's jump to this uh this tweet right
here and we'll get in one last segment
for uh for today from KRON 4 News San
Francisco police clarified that it would
not arm robots with guns instead they
would be equipped with explosives
well okay that's the future I was
looking forward to a robot dog runs up
to you and you go oh God and then it
blows up that's crazy and it would be
like a focused explosion so we're going
One Direction towards its Target and the
robot would probably be fine like I was
playing more Rumba I was driving in my
Tesla the other day and it's got Elon
announced everyone's getting full
self-driving now and it really is crazy
to experience the steering wheel
spinning by itself it just goes it just
Auto updated the car so Elon Tesla
rolled out all full self driving for
everybody you flick a little tab on the
screen and then all of a sudden your
car's Auto driving
I'm on it's like a three-lane uh six
Lane Highway like three and three and
there's there's a median if you want to
turn because it's a big Highway in the
middle of nowhere you pull into the
median and wait and so this truck pulls
in and stops and I'm and I'm my car
isn't self-driving got my hands on the
wheel and that just slams the brakes on
because it assumed that there was
something in the median coming towards
us I don't even know why and that's very
very dangerous but you know what you can
counteract that by just tapping the
accelerator and it just it cancels the
braking and keeps going that's what
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
be like hey you made a mistake car right
now imagine they get a robot dog with a
bomb on it and it makes that kind of
mistake the only difference is it
explodes in front of you and you can't
tap a break to Make It Stop So how you
guys doing we looking forward to our San
Francisco killer police robot future
what do we got people were masking up
you've got facial recognition is that
part of why we've introduced masks is
because people are they going to be able
to recognize your face with a mask on is
that what they're trying to do uh I
don't know I think they can recognize
you based off your your uh
the way you use a mouse they could find
out who you are and set up a specific
fat pattern they have gate recognition
if you're wearing a mask and walking it
can see how you're moving and then go we
know that is man the idea that a robot
could walk up to someone and blow them
up on the street is freaking nuts
especially in this country that's
freaking nuts I had a crazy thought
because uh Elon Musk is doing that
neural link update
implant in your brain then we're talking
about X phone and starlink I want you to
imagine this future when you're born the
doctor says do you want us to do the
neural link now yes oh he's getting
neural linked and they put the neural
Link in the brain then as you're getting
older but at this point starlink is
substantially more powerful you are
networked via satellite with your brain
your entire life
so you're walking around you don't have
a phone you're just getting the data
beamed to your brain and you're thinking
back and beaming data back and like
elon's the kind of living forever I
don't know about that he'd give you the
mental power to shut down drones from a
distance with your thoughts about you no
Elon would give the individual the
ability to shut those robot dogs down
he's that kind of Rebel but he's not
going to necessarily be in charge the
whole time perhaps I don't know if Elon
would do that I kind of feel like
they'll have the power to shut you down
you'll be walking around and you'll and
you'll walk into a pastry shop and
you'll say I'll have you're welcome to a
Starbucks I'll have the um egg bites and
the cold brew pumpkin spice and they're
gonna go that'll be five dollars and
you'll go okay
okay just just a minute something's
wrong
uh sorry sir if you can't pay I I don't
I don't understand it's not connecting
what's happening
report to the barracks no no all of a
sudden you you get um you hear in your
own mind you have been disconnected for
hurtful thoughts
cut you off you were you were thinking
to the network I'm imagining like if we
get to the point where it is neural link
people are getting brain implants star
links are gonna like yo he's building
more than just one thing you know what I
mean you like think your car pulls up
you get it then you're connected to the
network again no Escape yeah that's what
I said earlier aside up with the Messiah
um and people could even find someone
through their heartbeat I mean there's
the technology is is advancing so fast
and already it's being abused by so many
powerful people in so many horrible ways
with it becoming more integrated into
our lives we did having more power over
our lives the people screwing us over
with the technology that already exists
will only screw us over even more so you
think it's bad now it's probably going
to get a lot worse I started doing this
thing where I was thinking words instead
of saying them to people like I started
I started making YouTube videos in 06
and I was like well let's just tell all
my past Secrets let's get this out of
the way because they're distracting me
they're getting in my mind when trying
to have fluid thoughts so I was like oh
my grandpa Paul used to grab me when I
was a kid and abusive like and I would
be all honest about these horrible
things from my past things that I did
and all of a sudden I had completely
control my thoughts I no longer had
racing thoughts I just have an empty
brain where I can create any words I
want at any time for the most part and I
think that's how you counteract this
neural net crap with them trying to read
your thoughts you don't have any
and then you can make it hear what you
want it to hear that's a perfect
veganism I love it that was good
um but you know it's funny but you make
a point
uh I don't know how I think the
challenge is it takes a strong
meditative mind to counteract a probe in
your brain you know what I mean like try
and clear your mind and think of nothing
when you also have that Trope of don't
think of a white fence and then you
immediately do and it's like you can't
do anything about it man you see
Ghostbusters when Rey they're like no
one think anything he's like oh no the
Stay Puft Marshmallow Man I'm sorry I'm
sorry first thing that came into my mind
that's Gozer you know don't think about
anything
so I guess I wonder you know are we all
being led by Elon Musk the the Pied
Piper it's like the walrus and the
carpenter and he's dancing around and
we're all dancing along with him about
to go around the corner and get I feel
like he would know that he would see
that in the distance that he would know
that he could be used as a honey pot so
like he would have some protections
beforehand I'm saying he's doing it on
purpose like I'm saying is it possible
that he's like I'm here for free speech
everyone support me he gets everybody
rallying behind him because he knows
what public opinion is he starts doing
these things that won't stop his
technological advancements or plans and
you know maybe he thinks it'll be a good
thing you know we'll end all the hate
when everyone's wired into each other's
brains it's just confusing what his
motivation would be though like because
like I said earlier it's like what's
money to him like I mean suppose he
wants to do that like
doesn't that like make him even more
busy than he already is like he he just
like owns everything now like yeah would
he be like elected like a ruler at that
point because he would be more powerful
than the government at that point I mean
he wants to go to Mars yeah and and I
was I was talking about this a bit
earlier and I think we talked we may
talk mention it here
we we have
um there are a lot of human beings that
don't contribute uh to anything
I don't think people are uh required or
obligated to contribute to anything
humans are free to go and live on a farm
and live their lives and be happy but if
you're if you're looking at a shared
mission of the United States it's like
so few people are working towards any
kind of shared goal whereas in like
World War II yet basically everybody
working together
so if you're someone like Elon and uh
you want to colonize Mars you want to go
to other planets you you need a
substantially larger amount of active
people working towards this
infrastructure Elon says we need more
people he's right more people means more
Specialties means more technology means
better human better capabilities for men
but we have a lot of people who do
nothing you know like people who are
just like dancing in Times Square now I
got no beef with Times Square dancers I
think this stuff's really cool but it's
not going to contribute for the most
part to any kind of space travel or
world view or World Vision of someone
like Elon Musk
it may be relaxing and fun to watch it
may be entertaining that's good for you
but there's certainly certainly a lot of
people that aren't doing things in the
direction that a powerful individual
might want
so let's assume Elon Musk says it is
imperative that Humanity travels to the
stars because he really believes it
well then of course you would want
massive control over the narrative to to
create a space where everyone is working
towards a goal that he desires what is
money that's a good point Elon can only
buy so much but if you control the
culture of an entire country they will
willfully start building your rocket
ships yeah Manpower that's one of the
greatest things money can get you is
Manpower but people will do that for
free if they believe in you and it's not
and but there's also limits too some
people will be like you can't pay me
enough and I don't need your money you
you make you make a culture or Community
or or a group of people want to do it
and then you don't gotta you don't got
to worry about it excuse me yeah I'm
looking for the sound I'm really looking
forward to interviewing Elon
probably get them on the show pretty
soon I would imagine how busy is over
Twitter HQ can you set it up hey Alex I
mean I mean Ian is very confident
there's often where like Ian will be in
the beginning show like we should get
Brad Pitt on the show
I'm not culture crisis too right yeah if
we could confidence plays man it's like
I don't deep down I'm an insecure child
like everything I'm like terrified like
I'm this is all an act you know this
whole Ian Crossland character I've built
but I do believe we had Kanye a couple
days ago like the this is it man we're
coming together and we're gonna build a
space elevator Reach for the Stars
you know
I'm just like Ian how are we supposed to
book these people you know one step at a
time who else do you guys want what
what's the biggest guess do you think
you guys I could love to get Ron Paul on
the show love to I don't know what his
status is how how he's feeling we got to
go to Texas yeah we have to go set it up
let's go there's there's a lot of people
who are work with that are fans of Ron
Paul who have already told us like we
have to go to Texas and we can make
something happen let's set it up let's
do this Ron Elon I'd like to get what
about you Chris uh pavlovsky Bill ottman
Elon Musk like a bunch of CEOs of tech
companies the biggest the biggest guest
for the show what would it be plus
Schwab yeah I would love to sit down
with you yeah
come on the show yeah I would love to
talk to Mr Mr klausch and I would love
to talk to Mr Gates as well
um what about you Serge
sorry go ahead no I was gonna say class
is going to be like is there too many
people in there so we have to get rid of
them there's just too many of them who
do you want to see I'd love to speak to
Elon as well just as a South African who
may want to speak to a fellow South
African that's about it yeah I just say
Elon like typically when people are like
who would you rather have on the show
like who do you want to get on the show
I'm like I don't handle booking you know
Cassandra messages and finds people
before that was Lydia but if I there are
some times where I'll hit somebody up
and be like yo yo come hang out like I'd
love to be on the show Elon definitely
um Putin Kim Jong-un all of you guys you
guys have an invite here
would be a spectacular imagine what is
he going through right now I mean does
Kim Jong-un speak English I believe so
he went to Swift schools right right
yeah he does that would I would that's
that's a good point I would absolutely
let's go to Korea to talk to him
why not go to North Korea at the DMZ
yeah yeah yeah
I'll do it we did crazier stuff who
would be your favorite guest to have on
it probably Elon Musk yeah the time is
hot yeah it is well I I just think
elon's doing so much good you know as
much as I mentioned there's like maybe
he's got an agenda and stuff like that
it's because I'm not going to give
anybody a guarantee like I'm not going
to assume trust in anybody but I on the
surface the things that he's doing are
are absolutely admirable 100 and he's
extremely busy so I think the only way
we would be able to do it is if we go to
him set up a studio maybe outside of
Twitter HQ or anything and just like
come in come out right um and and so not
to waste it yeah at Twitter in and out
really quick they got the infrastructure
we can probably set up a studio in the
building make it reasonable so he
doesn't have to fly or spend a lot of
time we do the show on Twitter we stream
it on Twitter and then Elon tweets it
out and then that's um us having a
fantasy vision of what the best possible
or that's the way that's the way we
launch Twitter's partner program there
it is ah right
um um I am down uh absolutely officially
crossing over officially moving over to
a new platform that's going to be way
better than you know
and
officially launching the you know media
this New Media think about I think so
here imagine this guys for everybody
listening if we were on Twitter and
there was an easy like you go to you go
to twitter.com timcast and then it just
says like live there'll be like a tab
that says live now you click it and then
you'll get this video feed and you can
click retweet yeah that's it yeah think
about how big the show would be if like
everybody just clicked retweet right
there and it got shared to all these
feeds so that's why I'm like I would
absolutely love to stream to Twitter it
exists they don't have you know the
Super Chat function stuff like that but
uh that would be fantastic so that's why
you said to you know I tweeted at Elon I
was like do these things that would be
fantastic it's nuts yeah you can't read
he's probably setting up super chats
like why wouldn't he thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time